je reviens ce mec à 15 km de là où on se
trouve nous sommes actuellement dans le
centre de kiev dans la région des
districts de boudhha et du rhdp qui sont
devenus de fait depuis 48 heures le
front du nord-ouest pour cet assaut
qu'on attend de manière évidente sur sur
pierre et là on a vu évidemment c'est
assez d'ailleurs tragique est dramatique
et bien le scénario habituel vosu qui
demande qui impose des corridors
humanitaires et qui acquit acquis pied
d'accord pour ouvrir et infecter le feu
et à la mi journée nous étions dans ces
districts ans avec les convois de d'une
centaine de ses bus jaunes des puces
public qui tente qui ont été
réquisitionnés pour aller chercher des
centaines de civils qui sont bloqués
dans ces districts et bien à midi et à
13 heures il y a eu des tiers de tanguay
tirs d'artillerie extrêmement important
y avait des fumées noires tout autour de
là où se trouvait et donc dans une ak au
1t un descriptif ces convois ont pu
atteindre gucia et irbine le centre
évacué sous les tirs d'artillerie je le
répète et la protection des forces de
défense territoriale ukrainienne et
l'armée ukrainienne tous et si vite donc
dans cette dans ce secteur dix mille
civils qui étaient toujours bloqués dans
cette zone résidentielle qui est devenu
vraiment à fond une véritable zone de
guerre ont pu aller vers kiev ils sont
en sécurité en a t'il vers kiev et vont
sans doute être acheminés par train vers
d'autres endroits région de l'ouest du
pays
vers la frontière donc c'est ça la
réalité des et elle peut des corridors
humanitaires qui sont autant dire que tu
as à moscou et à kiev la réalité est
extradé jirs de nancy épuisement des
populations et surtout de non respect
des principes fondamentaux des deux des
droits de la de de la guerre c'est à
dire de l'été passé les civils de lévis
d'ukrainiens en dehors des groupes de
combat bonjour cyril stratégie de
l'épuisement vous le dixième à l'instant
toute la question bien sûr est
maintenant de savoir combien de temps
elle les ukrainiens vont vous résister
et légumes on est vraiment dans le
syndrome de david et goliath il faudrait
pas évidemment aller trop vite même le
long convoi et cette offensive qui avait
été pensé par l'armée russe sous les
éclairs il ya eu évidemment
ddd cueille logistique on le sait
maintenant cette offensive ne sera pas
aussi rapide que prévu l'app l'offensive
piétine mais pour autant attention
puisque s'il ya une mobilisation
extraordinaire il faut le dire de toute
la population ukrainienne mobilisation
des portes du chrétienne pour résister
notamment pour cet énorme à saulxures
symbolique sur la capitale kiev eh bien
il est en crue sont à moins qu'ils 15 km
de là où nous nous trouvons nous sommes
nous étions hier dans l'est dans la
district de boudhha et dire fine il y
avait des combats extrêmement intense
des maisons de civils qui ont été
touchés par des tirs d'artillerie donc
les temps que son ton porte de les tanks
russes ton temps porte de kiev et même
s'il ya une grande mobilisation encore
une fois du côté du très bien et une
résistance et thé russe est en crue ne
ferons pas demi-tour bien au contraire
et chacun était aussi encore une fois le
siège de kiev est inéluctable est ce une
question de jours difficile à dire les
américains s'en veut dire que c'était
absolument continent mais là aussi sur
le rapport de corps n'oublions pas que
il ya deux cent mille soldats russes sur
le tir lors du crâne actuellement qui
sont installés sont ci seront différents
qu'ils ont certes des villes entières
d'entre elles inventent et aussi mathieu
est inéluctable et ici ce matin par
exemple il fait extrêmement froid il
fait froid dit et on sent auprès des
peuples en revue les 100 civils mais
également sur le terrain avec les forces
d'autodéfense et des militaires déjà une
forme d'épuisement comme si tous les
efforts pouvait fournir les ukrainiens
sont déjà déployés en face d'une armée
qui est piétine qui va moins vite que
prévu mais qui est résolument décidé à
avancer vers tous ces points
stratégiques dont la capitale pour
partie